hi and thank you for having me
so today we're going to talk about
improving lives reducing costs
and simplifying decision making using an
enterprise pharmacogenomics program
really what we're going to talk about
are a few things including personalized
medicine and genetics
and how those impact the entire system
everything from employers and payers
down to health care providers and
the patients themselves the important
part of of all of what we do
first i'd like to talk about things that
a lot of us already know and talk about
and that's why is this important it
really is a financial and
health burden on society these days
prescription drug spending has exceeded
300 billion dollars a year
since 2015 adverse events those
those uh side effects that we all have
heard about whether they're ourselves
our parents our friends who have been on
medications
those adverse events actually cause
other issues emergency department visit
hospitalizations it's not always
headaches and belly aches
medication errors actually occur in 3.8
million
inpatient admissions and 3.3 million
outpatient visits a year
and unfortunately there are a
significant number of deaths attributed
to medication errors and adverse events
that we would talk about
but we can impact this and change things
and and one of the statistics that we
hear about and we realize why
making adjustments here are so important
is that one in four americans
take four or more prescription drugs
at a time now this equates to a large
pharmaceutical burden
and polypharmacy that's the number of
meds that a person is taking
for people taking those medications and
this is
higher health care costs drug
interactions those ddis that we talk
about in the clinic
medication non-adherence those are
people that don't want to take their
medications because of certain reasons
and it could be those side effects and
other reasons
decreased functional status and even
geriatric
syndromes but in all of this your dna
really matters so a drug can be toxic
but beneficial
toxic and non-beneficial non-toxic
beneficial
this is the same diagnosis and the same
prescription from patient to patient
and as we talk about personalized
medicine and personalized prescribing
we now have the opportunity to use
tools like pharmacogenomics and genetic
testing
to help with that prescribing so rather
than doing trial and error prescribing
like we have over the last
you know many centuries we can actually
check ahead of time in silico on a
computer
using genetics whether a drug is going
to be helpful
or not but i do want everybody here to
understand that dna
is not enough you also have to have a
really good understanding of the
other important issues when doing
prescribing
and these are things that our
pharmacists are already thinking about
usually right
we're talking about drug drug
interactions we're talking about
contraindications we're talking about
anticholinergic burden which is
something that describes the
cns depression that one might have i
often describe this as the benadryl
effect
it dries out a person it causes them to
be lethargic
um sometimes this is
what an older person might regard as
oh i'm just getting older right but we
realize it's their medications these
geriatric type syndromes it's the number
one cause of slip and falls in the
elderly
in our active working population if
you're a bus driver
or a mechanic working on a
warehouse floor you want to make sure
that this anticholinergic burden
is dealt with appropriately we also want
to look at black box warning on fda
labels
things like geriatric and pediatric
warnings and beers criteria
all of these are important lifestyle
warnings the things that we eat and
drink like alcohol and grapefruit juice
and leafy greens these all impact how
medications work so i'm i'm not a huge
fan
of the stoplight type red
yellow and green that one might see in
some typical pharmacogenomic reports
because it's not just pharmacogenomics
just because your genetics say that
you're okay to take a specific
medication
there might be other reasons not to take
those drugs
and there really is a huge cost to
getting this wrong
you have adherence appropriateness and
adversity
now it's easy for us to think about this
on a patient level
but we want to think about this
holistically how does the
system handle all of this when it
doesn't go right
what is the cost of getting it wrong and
what we know is that hospital admissions
go
up home health visits go up even the
number of laboratory tests go up
when all of this ma3 issues are not
contained
and so what we want to do is get this
right and we
see when you get ma3 right
you improve everything from patient
satisfaction and quality of life
issues their overall health but also
their
use of medications you also see a
reduction in adverse events
you see the costs to medication and
pharmacy claims
and total health care costs come down
and all of those things that i showed in
the previous slide
emergency department visits and
hospitalizations go down
the number of slip and falls decrease
and so really when we think about this
we're addressing the quadruple aim in
healthcare
or the triple aim depending on how you
think about this
and this is considering health care
workers
right the care team and their well-being
we want to be able to address all of
these
prescription issues these personalized
medicine
issues without burdening the health care
provider
with being a geneticist or being a
pharmacist or being an expert in all of
these spaces we want to empower them
to be able to take all of this
information and utilize it quickly
the same is true by improving quality of
care
we want to address each patient's goals
to improve
safety and efficacy and every patient
has a different goal
right whether it's playing with the
grandkids walking the dog again
or or just feeling better and not having
headaches
we want those better outcomes in the
improved population health
this isn't only individual to individual
we want to see
our older population feeling better we
want to see our active well population
doing better as well it improves public
health
overall and of course we all want to
reduce
and lower costs
so what i'm going to talk about today is
an entire
program that goes from population
analytics this idea of
who's going to benefit the most take
this
now i'll be the first to tell you i
think that eventually in a few years or
maybe even sooner
we'll all know our pharmacogenomics
we'll know all about ourselves and our
genetics and it'll be on our smartphones
or carry a usb or some kind of stick
along with us
so we have that information with us all
of the time
but i think to better society and help
with the public health issues right now
we really need to address these
issues and those people who are going to
benefit
the most first and to be able to do that
you have to have
metrics on top of things and understand
the population analytics
and so in any program that you're
considering to do
and roll this out to a large population
i really recommend that population
analytics to understand
who am i working with what does my
population look like who's going to
benefit the most from this
that should be looked at as a primary
source of information
then we have member engagement and it
never ceases to amaze me the really
smart
intelligent questions that i get from
folks who are not geneticists not
pharmacists
not physicians and prescribers the
people the members that were enrolling
in these programs are very interested in
their health
and so part of member engagement is
education
and making enrollment as easy as
possible without having to jump through
hoops
the genetic testing at this point has to
be cost
effective and comprehensive and specific
for the drugs and genes
that are actionable in the clinic
medically relevant and clinically
actionable is a term that i often repeat
over and over and over again because i
want everybody to understand that we
don't want to
burden our health care providers with
just informative
pharmacogenomic information it's not
helpful
we all know about alert fatigue if we're
just throwing informative information
where references need to be read we're
not going to get
the outcomes that we're looking for in
these programs
and so genetic testing needs to come
with very very specific information
on how the information can be used in
the clinic
and this comes down to the fourth box
that i have here on pharmacy
medication therapy management review or
comprehensive medication management
the idea is that our pharmacists are
already
thinking in this way and they're already
used to
uh incorporating genetics with lifestyle
with ddis and anticholinergic burden and
beers criteria and all these other risk
factors that i mentioned earlier
into one conversation and
by empowering them with decision support
tools good clinical decision
support tools that allow the physician
to or that i'm sorry the pharmacist to
see
all of this information in one place and
make
good well-informed thoughtful decisions
and communicate that to the prescribing
physician
all of a sudden we've got an entire
program that runs from understanding who
to test
engaging those people testing them and
communicating and making changes
and then there's a slide here or a box
that i don't have that's the feedback
loop
that once things are changed
understanding how that's improving
the health of both the system
the health care provider and the patient
themselves
so i'll give you an example of how we at
coreo life sciences have rolled this
out we have a
a decision support tool called gene dose
live
and in this system the pharmacist can go
in and see all of the medications that
the phys
that the patient is taking and all of
those
risk factors and it's boiled down into
this beautiful easy to understand
chart so that the pharmacist can do
triage very quickly
they see a large bar the larger the bar
the more the risk and they can see where
that risk stems from whether it is
genetic
or another piece of information but
what's really powerful about a tool like
this
is it provides the pharmacists with the
ability to
in silico audition alternative
medications
they can review the medication that
their patient has taken
but also on the computer test which ones
are going to be
more safe and more effective so let's
say a patient was taken an uh
antidepressant a tricyclic
antidepressant
there's something like 74 medications on
the market in the u.s
both over the counter and prescription
and even supplements that people can get
at
at their local drug store
and for use as antidepressants
in the system if you see a risk for the
antidepressant
you would then be able to say well i
need to change that medication you would
click
on that drug and it would give you the
other meds in that
same therapeutic class and would show
you the risks
involved in in changing the medication
to something else so for each of those
74 alternatives you would understand the
potential risk
so now we don't have to give the person
that medication
and wait for six or eight weeks which is
the length of time it takes for a
patient to see the benefits of an
antidepressant
we don't have to wait anymore we can
increase
the chance of hitting the right
medication by using genetics and these
other risk factors
this risk analytics engine
allows the pharmacist to see
all of those risks and which patients
are going to be ill-suited or which
pills are ill-suited for a patient
and again like i said before it shows
you
which drugs are more or less
risky we can also include
formularies from different hospital
systems in here
and really include the other risk which
is
pricing information so we include things
like the generic
price and the brand name price if a drug
is too expensive and the patient doesn't
take it
it's as good as you know it's
it's no good at all right we want our
patients to adhere to the meds that
they're being prescribed
but we also want to report this to the
pharmacist
or to the prescribing physician in a way
that they understand it
and the medication action plan that
comes out of this system
provides results on which drugs to
remove
which to add and which to change and
that could be
dosing time of day route of
administration
and then which drugs not to touch it
boils down
all of this information and for
polypharmacy patients that might be on
15 medications or more
it makes it very easy to have the
conversation
with the prescribing physician so in our
remaining few moments here i'd like to
provide
some insight and a case study we've been
working with the teachers retirement
system
of the state of kentucky for a few years
now the average
age of their members is 74 years old
they have about 37 000 um
retired teachers as part of their mehp
program which is their medicare eligible
health care program
um in that there are 7 000 retired
teachers who are over the age of 65
and they join at age or i'm sorry
they're over the age
of 80 but they join at the age of 65.
so in a population like this you'll soon
see the benefit
of enrolling them as early on as we can
because they're part of the system for
so long
and genetics don't change throughout the
lifespan
of the member so while genetics stay the
same these other lifestyle
and drug interactions and and uh
indications and diseases that a member
might
be suffering those change and that's why
a program that keeps this stuff live
things like gene dose live that allow
you to change that you might be pregnant
now but not nine months right you might
be suffering from oncologic
issues now but not in three years
and so whereas the genetics don't change
these other surrounding issues do
so a system that allows you to
take account of all of this is really
important
interestingly enough there are two
members of their group that are 108 one
of them may have had a birthday might be
109 now
but of those 36 37 000 retirees they're
age
65 to 108
and we enrolled so far voluntarily
they've been
introduced to the program provided
educational material that tells them
about the cost it tells them about
privacy and all of these details they've
been interested in
and we enrolled them and we've enrolled
just shy of 30 percent of that
population to date
early on even before we started
enrolling
we understood that a lot of these
members
are taking medications 15
medications was the average number of
prescriptions that
members were taking and these folks
aren't outliers the u.s
we see that across the entire population
and it might not be surprising to you
that 75
of them had high blood pressure heart
disease they had high cholesterol
pain and inflammation other
comorbidities
like diabetes and depression and pain
management issues that we all
know are an issue in our elderly or our
actively aging population
as part of that public health analysis
at the very beginning
we realized that 83 of those members
were already taking a medication known
to be impacted by genetics
let me say that again we know that 83
of those folks are taking at least one
drug where pharmacogenomic information
is going to be impactful to their
prescribing
so this is a population where
pharmacogenomics and these other risks
could actually be really really helpful
and we know based on the drugs that
they're taking
everything from the drugs that treat
depression
to pain management to cardiology to
gastroenterology
we know that they have misdirected spend
and these drugs should be
changed so they're not going to see the
financial return of just taking a person
off a medication
because every time we take somebody off
a man we probably need to replace it
with something else
now what we actually see in real life is
that over time
people start being on fewer medications
once their meds
are are handled better
and those are drugs that might be
dealing with those side effects
over the course of time when we did our
first
in our initial evaluation we realized
that
there was a huge impact of
pharmacogenomics on this population
in fact about 64 of the medication
action plans resulted in recommended
changes to plan
so out of all of these members who
enrolled the 9
000 of them even when we were looking
several months ago
a large number of them were benefiting
from
having a review by a pharmacist
in fact the top five most frequently
removed drugs
were removed specifically because
genetic concerns and this is dictated
and noted uh by the pharmacists in
the clinical decision support tool
itself
and so quickly i want to talk about the
outcome of this program and first of all
is the reduction in these medication
these ma3 related risk incidents so i
talked earlier about the ma3 incidence
and these are the cpt
codes or rather the icd-10 codes and the
indications the diseases and the things
that happen
the the events and the incidents that
happen to folks
that we know are impacted by
pharmacogenomics
and through our evaluation we saw a
downward trend
in the utilization of the health care
system following map delivery
over the course of the time afterwards
and that was in 13 there was a 13
reduction in those ma3 events
so hugely impactful
even more exciting to the the system
is understanding that cost reduction so
folks that had been
enrolled since january of 2018
were coming on three years for some of
these folks as they rolled
out the program and after the maps were
delivered we saw a 14
reduction in the cost to plan spending
over the
16 months following map delivery
now what's interesting and probably not
surprising to most of you
our internal control group this is
people
in the system that had not gone through
pharmacogenomic testing
they had not received a medication
action plan their physicians and
pharmacists were not involved
they actually had an increase of about
3.2 percent
in that cost to spending
the other metrics of success that we saw
in this program
are wrapped around the number of
recommendations accepted by prescribers
right these are naive prescribers so our
ability to communicate
uh changes in the plan well and
including pharmacists
that number is really impressive early
on in these programs
one might imagine that if you just have
pharmacogenomics
the recommendations aren't always
accepted by prescribers but we've seen
that number go
up over time and by including the other
risk factors
and by including good communication
between the pharmacists
in our team and the prescribing
physicians
we've also seen a reduction 11 percent
specifically in pharmacy spend okay
so you've got all of that total health
care costs have gone down the pharmacy
spend has gone down
and we've also seen a reduction in
hospitalizations
we've seen a reduction in emergency
department visits
and we've seen a 27 percent reduction in
slip and falls
i'd like to think that everybody here
knows somebody who's affected
by medications that just don't work
and wouldn't you like to help those
folks
when those medications don't work or if
they're harmful
knowing that there's ways to do it using
genetics and making that a complete
story using these other risk factors
that are impactful
when considering the health and wellness
of our
society thank you so much for your time
and i look forward to hearing your
questions
after this